from mesmerizing acts that blew the
house down your body just takes over two
performances that didn't exactly blow
the judges away given the history of
America's Got Talent that was the worst
live performance I've ever seen there
were moments tonight where I'm like what
the hell the quarterfinals on Tuesdays
America's Got Talent was quite a roller
coaster ride
hey Dance Crew the unbeatable who earned
Dwayne Wade's golden buzzer stole the
show with their high-energy routine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you've been breaking the internet with
your videos and now you just perform on
the world's biggest stage how did it
feel it feels amazing it's the world's
biggest uh platform for anybody so yeah
we are in the Dolby theatre right now in
the exten achievement itself was we
never thought we can be here so it
really feels amazing you know I've never
seen anything like that in my life
it was more dangerous than anything I've
ever seen more exciting more musical
than anything I've ever seen before but
it wasn't all praise the judges um Simon
felt some acts failed to deliver like
married couple Nick and Lindsay she was
doing with the knife trying to kill you
is what I was thinking when I heard you
sing that was the worst live performance
I've ever seen we want to show America
musicians which I think really hasn't
been the main focus at this time and we
want to do it right so we can win Simon
over because he's always attacking my
husband's voice and it makes me crazy
thirteen year old singer Charlotte
summers sounded great but Simon really
wasn't feeling her cover of Rihanna's
hit diamonds that was a terrible
terrible terrible song choice for you
and it didn't go as I planned but I'm
really proud of myself I think I did a
good job I mainly pushed them so the
better you know because you know for me
with you and I know whether you're a kid
you're coming on to get advice so you've
been improved that's part of the
learning curve you want to get the show
business
these are auditions contortionist marina
Mazeppa got similar feedback after her
routine to a Billy Eilish mashup this
started off a bit crazy and then it just
for me got boring
I hated the music I'm sad about Simon
back I didn't expect this
was like I would stop light balance kids
also perform to a Billy Eilish track
dislike would it had previously it
didn't have the wow factor I didn't like
the music Simon spoke with et backstage
where he clarified he's absolutely a
pili Eilish fan I didn't think in the
context of that performance that was the
right song yeah I just would have
changed the whole style of direction of
the soul there's nothing personal she is
brilliant
[Applause]
[Music]